hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to the game engine series
thursdays is game engine series day
hazel 2d day or at least thursday's in
like australian time that's why today i
started the day off with doing a four
hour live livestream four hours 16
minutes just working on hazel 2d and
figuring out what we're doing this
episode this is every thursday every
thursday on twitter tv slash the churner
definitely check that out if you're
interested in a little bit more of a
deeper look into what actually goes into
like you know hazel 2d um and every kind
of
i guess every decision that's made by me
every problem that i suffer through all
of the debug stuff because what i do is
i basically live stream everything on
twitch like i've been doing every
thursday this is the second consecutive
thursday and i made it so you know we're
going strong um but basically this is
what we are going to be taking a look at
today it's going to be based entirely
off of this live stream i've already
kind of got the code written and
furthermore after the code is basically
done i push it onto
the public hazel repository in the dev
branch you can see
literally just straight out of that four
hour live stream i'm now recording this
this episode so it really truly is game
engine day or game engine series day but
anyway the point is that um all the
stuff that i produce out of that live
stream usually i will push that into
this branch so if you want like to be a
little bit closer involved with the
development of hazel 2d definitely check
out both the hazel repository this dev
branch right but then also the actual
twitch live stream where i will be
streaming every thursday they just
wanted to kind of give a little bit like
of a reiteration as to where we're at
and how the how the development's
actually going now that being said
another great kind of thing to come out
of this is that i can kind of show you
guys what we'll be achieving in today's
episode ahead of time i mean i'm sure
you could just jump to the end and take
a look at it but if we actually dive in
into hazel and take a look at um you
know what is in that dev branch
currently in the code that we have you
know we've gone from basically just
being able to uh you know render a pink
cube hit play we can see it to now
actually having like physics where we
can hit play and you can see we actually
have like box 2d physics running so that
all happened like we went from zero to
that to this working in like four hours
right and that was all live streamed um
of course i had you know big boy hazel
hazel 3d hazel dev whatever i had that
for reference and that's kind of how i
built that stuff but again point being
if you want to see that whole process
head on over to twitch because this is
going to be a condensed version where
i'm going to do it for the second time
but now in front of you guys and
hopefully maybe even explain a little
bit more so without further ado let's
dive in and take a look at what's going
to take to make that stuff happen i just
feel energized today to be honest
because again just done so much so much
stuff um there's actually a few other
things that went into it that i'm not
going to talk about right but i am
mostly going to be using this as like
kind of like a diff so that i can
actually see what's going on because
obviously the all of the changes are
kind of here and we're going to kind of
start with that
but the first thing i'll do is actually
uh check out a copy of the master branch
i think okay so what i have here is a
completely fresh checkout of the master
branch but it looks like it doesn't even
compile and so i want to talk a little
bit about this because i went through
this on stream and i think it was kind
of uh it probably will be useful to some
people so first of all why doesn't it
compile it's a fresh checkout yeah it
doesn't compile
surprisingly not my fault um because
people seem to have like accepted pull
requests without even checking to see if
it like compiles or whatever i think the
problem is
this actually it is this so this log.h
file uh now includes stringcast from glm
and that's like a gtx thing
anything in gtx is like uh experimental
as far as i'm aware so um it's good that
we have these operators now it's fine
but again it doesn't compile because you
have to enable the experimental thing
now you can just look at the kind of log
i guess and see what's changed recently
if you knew that it did compile at some
point but i'll show you how to kind of
diagnose an issue like this because it
can be annoying so what does the output
say well the output says
there's a fatal error glm gdx dual
quaternion is an experimental extension
blah blah if you double click on this
you get taken to dual quaternion.hpp and
then we we see the error it's just a
hash error the compiler compiler's
giving us an error because this is not
defined so we need to define this
somewhere but how do we even know what's
pulling in this header file so the way
that i like to do this is first of all
you need to figure out like what you're
trying to compile that doesn't compile
this right so if we look at like the
output it can be a little bit hard to
tell what even tried to happen but
you know if you look at this build
starter project hazel it says h.p.c.h
and then immediately the error right so
most likely it couldn't compile the
pre-compiled header so the next step is
to open up the compiled header and just
hit control f7 on the cpp file this is
just to confirm that we are in the right
place and you can see that in fact yes
the pre-compiled header it's this is the
physical cpp file that's trying to be
compiled and it cannot be compiled
because uh obviously we're getting this
hash error so now we have the tedious
issue of like but but which one of these
header files includes that so
easiest way to check at least in my
experience is to go back to that cpp
file um and then if you go to properties
right click properties or alt enter as i
just pressed if you go into um
cc plus plus and then like i never know
where it is so i end up going to all
options and searching maybe it's in
advanced
yeah it is in advance so
show includes right and you can just
enable it just for that file you can
enable for your whole project but that's
unnecessary so just for this file we'll
enable show in close we'll set that to
yes and then now when i hit ctrl f7
i'll see the entire like hierarchy of
stuff that's been included now usually
it's a bit hard to deal with here so i
can just control a control c that
and then if i open up vs code
which
is a command for some reason and it's
just a bit weird but if i open that up
let me just try and get a blank thing
going
and if i paste that in here now i have
this text here and it's a bit easier to
deal with i can find the file that's
causing the error which is i think it's
this one dual quaternion but i can make
sure by just double clicking it yeah so
it is dual quaternion.hpp
i can find this
dual paternity or hpp i can see what's
including it which looks to be it's
included once and it's included here and
then i can be really cool with this
multi-line thing in in vs code and i can
just middle click drag up and i'm just
trying to basically just form a line to
see the first thing this is great isn't
it to see the first thing that crosses
that line to the left right i may have
already gone past it i don't know i
wasn't really looking um so this is this
touches it i'm not interested in that
i'm interested in stuff that's to the
left side of it so apparently nothing
yet
um let's keep oh there we go right and
then you can see oh look
so the first the file that includes that
file that's what i'm looking for what
file includes that file it's gtx
stringcast.hpp that's this what includes
that oh look it's one of our files log.h
and of course we knew that from looking
at the diffs and looking at the actual
commits but log.h is the file so going
back here going to log.h
we'll obviously see that it includes
that stringcast as it said in the kind
of show includes thing over here right
so then we're like oh okay so including
this is the problem and what is the
problem the problem is that we need to
define that um
kind of well we have to have that define
jill enable experimental if we want to
be able to actually include it now two
there's a lot of ways you could do this
we could stick this in like a breaking
ball header we could um you know we
could uh actually make the define be
part of
the pre-make build so that whenever we
build a hazel file that already has that
defined um i don't know to be honest
what it should be i'm pretty sure we do
define this in other places yeah we do
it in math.cpp we do it in a bunch of
places so just for now i'll just do it
here as well so we'll define that before
we include that file and then the other
thing i'll do uh quickly is i'll
actually drop this below this right so
usually what we do with hazel is we like
to include our files first and then
anything external just so that like just
in case we have certain definitions or
certain other configurations pushing
warnings whatever it might be
that we actually want to kind of take
effect before we actually pull in
external code so usually we do that um
but yeah that's pretty much how i would
go around go about fixing and finding
the
like where that actually is where that
problem is um
because it can be obviously a complete
nightmare to be like oh no this is being
included but from where and obviously
recursive like not recursive includes
but includes nested it includes like
it's it can be an absolute nightmare to
debug so
that's kind of step one
in this episode a little bit annoying
but um
uh fixed
uh you know um i guess i'll
not being defined
in
fix that not being defined in
log.h
um
in race and commit so yeah so but just
for the future um obviously make sure
you test you test your pull request i'm
not sure how that would have compiled um
unless and again obviously i just did a
fresh checkout i ran set up i you know
did regenerate i did generate my
projects for the first time so it wasn't
something that might have also been in
pre-make like defining that or whatever
so um make sure code compiles that
that's you know step one is compiling
step two is running
try not to fail step one at least um but
yeah so that's the first thing i wanted
to mention uh other than that we can
just get right into basically um
figuring out uh everything that needs to
go into box2d so the first thing i want
to start with is if you guys don't know
what box 2d is it's a
it's a pretty good it's a great i'll say
it's a great 2d physics library you
should start with this
right i have used this for years so i
kind of know how it works so i'm not
going to bore you with this here i'm not
going to teach you box cd because they
have pretty good documentation boxer.org
documentation
start with the overview go through this
it literally like just explains
everything really well there's a hello
box 2d which goes through how to create
a world you can see how good they have
little snippets of source code it's
fantastic this is how you learn how to
do this stuff right um i would
definitely recommend taking a look at
this it's probably a good thing for me
to read it as well because 2.4.1 don't
think i've used that version yet and um
you know i'm sure there's a lot of stuff
that i didn't read initially and
probably some new stuff so start with
the documentation for sure
but then um obviously we're gonna brush
past that the other thing that i like to
do that i do with a lot of the sub
modules is i fork them so i forked box
2d already
i actually updated this
recently i think so you can see we're
like in sync we're kind of ahead because
we've got our own commits here but the
reason i do this um i explained it
during the live stream i might even
i don't know might talk about this some
other time as well but uh the point
being is that i like to
i like to fork repositories and put them
kind of under my control so that i can
freely modify them not just like add a
premade file because i want to compile
this through pre-make you can see how
easy this script is right box 3d is a
great example of just being easy to
compile no real problems with the build
there but um i can just easily make my
own pre-make file and add that there so
that i can use it with the rest of like
hazel's build system but also
i can modify stuff so i'm goi is a great
example we have done a lot of
modifications to imgui um written custom
code you know i fixed bugs in there um
that's
kind of important to be able to do if
you're running a game engine you don't
want to just depend on someone else's
repository unless it's really immutable
in the sense that like you're never
going to be modifying their code yeah
you can make them you can make them
directly a sub module otherwise i like
to fork it then make the fork a sub
module right that's what i've been doing
this thus far so i've already done that
this has been around for a long time but
today four hours ago i when i started
that live stream i
updated it to the latest version so that
it was basically in sync with master
right from the original repository over
here okay so that's kind of um
that's kind of where we sit with box 2d
so that means we can easily just go to
our
um repository and just add it as a sub
module right so git sub module add
the url and then um hazel
vendor and then box 2d i'll add it with
the capitalization like this hit enter
and it's going to
it's going to clone it okay you can see
how quick that was actually i mean
probably not because i cut but it was it
was like seconds one other thing i want
to mention about forking as well is that
a lot of the times these repositories
contain so much extra stuff so like for
example this test bed like you know this
if you look at this this is like a full
on like i'm gui and like you know
testing like box 2d i don't need that it
should be part of the main repository of
course but like i don't need that right
so i can just i haven't done it in this
case but i could just delete that from
the fork and therefore i'm making like
the whole hazel solution a little bit
lighter right i mean i don't think i'm
including that testbed stuff in the
build i'm not just source and include
but still like those files have to be
cloned and pulled down we don't need
that right
um there's another reason why i like to
do this but anyway so we've got that sub
module um it's set now now all we have
to do because again i've already written
the premade file for it this sub module
is in use by
big hazel as well not just hazel 2d um
which is this version that we're working
on here the game engine series so we've
been using it for a while but um hazel
vendor box 2d it's here right and it's
got a pre-made file so all i have to do
is like add it as a as a like i have to
include it into my pre-make file and add
it as a dependency so i'll open up
dependencies.lua and pre-make 5.lua so
i probably will try and keep them kind
of in alphabetical order maybe i'll have
the lowercase guys first here for
whatever reason um
i don't know what order to put these in
like you could try grouping them by
categories like this stuff is all kind
of graphics related glm's like math it's
kind of core i guess entity like shaders
i don't know i'm just going to put it up
here
workspace location hazel vendor then
box2d
and then box2d doesn't that that does in
fact have
a
folder called include which has all that
stuff there now we don't need to include
the library directory because we're not
linking it as an external library we're
actually compiling it ourselves so
because of that we can just go to
pre-make five dot lower and over here in
dependencies we can just include it
again i'll include it kind of in
alphabetical order kind of and actually
i guess that is an alphabetical order
except for that but um box duty is now
included so it should be included in our
dependencies over
here sorry over here dependencies
um
but then there's a few other things we
have to do to specifically hazel to
actually link the library
and also add those include directories
that we just defined in dependencies so
if we go to
um
let's say hazel and then look at hazel's
premade file
then we can say that we want to link box
2d again i'll do it in alphabetical
order it shouldn't matter too much
um and uh the include directory again i
guess in alphabetical order so box 2d
and i think that's it
i think that's literally it
so you can see how easy it is to set
this up if you already have that
pre-make file so now i'll just
regenerate those projects again you can
see it's made the box 2d stuff
if i hit reload
then i guess the pre-make files are
included in pre-make that's kind of nice
right
yeah that that that's nice i didn't
notice that before um anyway so we have
box 2d here let's right-click and hit
build try and compile it should compile
without problems i hope
debug x64 my visual studio lately by the
way has been just a complete disaster i
don't know what's going on like look at
it it's just frozen now just frozen
trying to compile stuff there we go
finally started the build
and there you go you can see how quick
that was of course with multi-processor
compile enabled and my like 16 cores
it's pretty quick but um
that's done no warnings no nothing we
have the lib file and it should be
linkable and everything should be great
so that is how we add a sub module
really easy stuff
uh again box2d is quite a simple example
weren't many source files nothing really
too you know it's just math basically
box city so it's it's easy to work with
okay so let's pop into this and see what
we can do i'm just gonna hit a five to
to run this
um
it should just link it i think i added
it like i didn't forget to add it to the
linking did i um let's compile the rest
of the engine visual studio is not
responding i don't know what's going on
probably need to wire my computer again
or get a new computer because this guy
is getting old
um anyway while that's going though um
let's uh talk a little bit about our
strategy here so what i want to do is
like the idea itself is really easy and
as i mentioned looking at the
documentation is the best the best way
to get started but what i'm going to do
today is specifically just make it like
you know i'll get it to the state that i
showed you in
showed you at the beginning of the
episode look at this it's still not
responding what a pile of trash anyway
as i mentioned we'll get to the state
that i showed you in the beginning of
the video but to do that all we really
need to do is basically i don't think we
have now seen in our same class i don't
think we have an actual like entry point
that we established like a runtime start
function you know editor layer we made
that um on scene play or something like
that we made that function uh i think
last episode which i'll have linked up
there by the way i should've done that
it'll probably be linked since the
beginning
since the beginning of the episode but
basically
you know we have that play button but it
needs to actually trigger something in
the scene because at that point we
actually want to initialize the box 2d
world
and populate it with all of the rigid
body 2d components that we're about to
create and then all of the you know box
colliders or whatever else we have
so that needs to happen when we hit play
and then obviously every frame on update
we then need to actually simulate that
physics world and then that's basically
it so the way that it works um probably
worth explaining actually i didn't even
think about this i was just going to jam
in the code but i guess if you've never
done this before it might not make too
much sense so let me switch back to my
screen again this is very crude because
i didn't prepare for this we're gonna
we're gonna just maybe i can um
fill this with just like black or
something and then draw in white so that
my screen isn't so my um
face isn't overexposed that's the real
reason yeah i guess i can so basically
the way that this works um in paint is
uh you know we have this kind of
box 2d world which contains a
representation so i'll call this box2d
world this contains a representation of
all of the actual physical bodies that
we have in our scene so we call these
rigid bodies they are literally if you
just imagine like oh i have you know if
we look back to that scene that i showed
at the beginning of this episode we have
like a box we have another box this is
like kind of like the floor this kind of
moves around and bounces around right so
these are both rigid bodies this one we
call a static rigid body because it does
not move right or at least it doesn't
like it it's not really affected by
gravity or by physics itself you can't
push this around of course
programmatically you can decide to move
it somewhere else but
it doesn't get simulated right it
basically adds as it acts as like a
fixture as like something that's
permanently fixed
now this on the other hand is a dynamic
rigid body um in the sense that like
when you hit play it will fall right if
this was also dynamic the floor would
just fall and that would be useless
right that way this is kind of fixed
it's being kind of held by imaginary
pins of course in the real world we have
like you know the earth floating in
space it has a gravitational center this
isn't really the case for box 2d or
anything so that's why we have this
concept of static because we need to be
able to fix something in space otherwise
everything moves and that's a disaster
right so we have these rigid body 2ds
they also have something called a
collider right they have to have a
collider which specifies what part of it
actually kind of gets uh sent to the
physics system so the fact that we're
rendering this as like a square and i
think that's all great that has nothing
to do with like the physical
mathematical representation
of
um our actual bodies here right so
usually what happens is um you know
physics libraries like box2d like to
deal with half extents so in other words
you have a position which is basically
the center of the object and then you
have a half extent which is basically
kind of like the radius instead of the
diameter right so it's not the total
length of this thing it's from that it's
from that position point how long till
the edge right so in other words if this
was a one by one meter square like this
then obviously you'd have a 0.5 by 0.5
kind of box collider extent right that
would be the size of the box collider
0.5.5
so that's how we basically like this
mathematical representation we give to
box2d and then it's able to basically
run a simulation right so this will fall
on that mathematical representation but
then what we want to do is show that so
we need to basically take that back and
render that on the screen somehow right
so how do we currently render things
well we use the transform component
right so we have it we have a transform
that contains like our translation
rotation scale right that's what we use
to actually physically draw this so if
we want to draw it down here now right
we need to obviously pull that data from
box 2d so in other words in this case
we'd be pulling well you know this is 2d
physics so we just need the xy position
right of where it is there is no z
positions that is zero and then we also
pull just the z rotation right so in
other words you can't rotate it in 3d
space you can't just suddenly make it
kind of lie down like that it's going to
be like rotated this way right so that's
a bad drawing rotated this way right
which is obviously going to be through
that kind of depth that z axis so that's
what you need to do um we need to pull
that back so in other words we first
basically when we hit play we give box
2d all of these representations all
these mathematical representations we
tell it hey this is static there's a lot
of other
kind of properties as well like you know
the friction of a surface the bounciness
or the restitution of a surface like
there's a few different other things
like the density how heavy is it stuff
like that you know we can give it um way
more parameters than just like this is
where it's located and that's it we can
give it like physics material properties
basically but at the end of the day you
know this is just what we're dealing
with right we're dealing with these
parameters that we give to box to d and
that happens when we hit play now every
frame we need to update
all of these bodies right so we
basically tell the box 2d world to
simulate our physics and then once it
does that once the simulation has
completed right we need to actually
go through all of these box 2d bodies
basically and pull this orange data back
and apply it to our transform component
before we render it and then we render
it and then everything's great it's been
affected by physics now there's a few
important things to note here right
feeling energy i'm standing still we're
standing during the entire four hour 15
minute live stream and i'm still
standing have not sat down today that's
that's how that's how into game engine
series day i am but anyway so the other
important thing to note here for sure is
that
since we are pulling our transform data
and overriding our transforms every
frame from box 2d that means the
transform component can't really be used
anymore you use it initially to set up
where you want to be in the world right
because when we create those bodies in
the first place when we hit play
right where does it get the stuff for
like where the body should be from the
transform component so that still acts
that still works in that regard but then
if we suddenly decide through our
c-sharp script in the future that we
want to move a body we can't just set as
transform because that's not going to do
anything when it gets simulated it's
going to set it to whatever the box 2d
value is useless right so instead of
doing that what you need to realize is
that if you are if you are a rigid body
if you have that rigid body 2d component
right then you you are owned by the
physics system that means that if you
want to suddenly decide that i want to
teleport myself somewhere else into the
level during gameplay you tell box2d to
do that for you right because again
box2d becomes the authority for the
transform essentially of the actual
object of the entity so that's important
to note as well you can't just set the
transform not gonna work you could make
it work if you wanted to if you really
wanted that api i want to set the
transform because obviously behind the
scenes in the c plus code you could be
like
if the transform is being set from c
sharp and i'm a rigid body then redirect
that transform setting to box 2d you
could do that internally but
i find it's a little bit better to just
be aware of how it works i guess and of
course in your c-sharp logic code you
could also be like if this has a
rigidbody2d component set it that way
otherwise set the transform directly so
whatever anyway that's the plan
hopefully that explanation was kind of
useful
now we're going to dive in and actually
start doing all of the work so
this has finally
loaded by the way
so if we go to scenes uh and yeah we've
just got the pink cube here we hit play
everything works um now we can actually
compile and run that's kind of nice but
of course we don't have any 2d stuff so
how do we even set something up right so
if i go control n i'm going to set up
and by the way during the live stream i
was very
annoyed with the fact that there's so
many things missing like we can't
duplicate entities control s didn't
exist during the live stream i ended up
adding it so we can only save as we
can't even save right so i might i don't
know if i'll do that today i might just
merge it in or something i don't think
that's that interesting uh but basically
if we create a kind of sprite render
entity our first goal i'll create um
i'll call this our sprite right i'll
create a
camera
as well call it camera
and this camera the first goal of the
camera will switch it to like
perspective and then i think we'll just
pull it back a bit now if i hit play you
should see that that's great so now
we're going to save as i'm going to go
into assets scenes and we're going to
call this the same thing it was in the
dev branch physics 2d dot hazel done
so now if i go to uh you know pink cube
and then go back to here you can see
that it saves my scene and everything
works wonderful i want to make this fall
that's step one right if it's really
part of the box 2d world when i hit play
it should fall
right if it's a dynamic rigid body how
do i make it a dynamic rigid body well i
would want to go to add a component and
add
rigidbody2d and then also add a box
collider2d so we clearly need all those
components but in the first place we
need to even get boxcity into our engine
i mean it's already compiling as part of
our engine but obviously we don't have
it
doing anything
whatsoever so this is now where i'm
going to refer to the code that i wrote
during the live stream
because i obviously don't remember
everything that happened so basically
the first thing we need to do is store a
box2d world right again consult the box
city documentation but this is called a
b2 world now i don't want to include box
2d here because if i do that c dot h is
likely i mean it's definitely included
by hazelnut it's incl it's going to be
included by the runtime potentially and
stuff like that i want to keep box 2d as
like a hazel thing only so i don't want
to have to link box 2d and like use you
know set up the include directories for
box 2d for every project from here on
out that uses hazel i want it to be a
dependency of hazel not of everything
that hazel uses so because of that i'm
going to do a four declaration here so
b2 world right
has to be outside of the name space here
i could put it here and just do like a
blank namespace but i'm not going to do
that and then we're going to add it as a
raw pointer yeah that's right
unfortunately unique pointers can't be
um
incomplete types so
otherwise i'd probably use a unique
pointer or something but then again we
are actually manually going to be
creating this and destroying this
pointer
when it comes down to
starting and ending our runtime which
would be a good place to introduce this
so on runtime start
and on runtime stop so these two
functions which i might hook up
immediately so that i don't so i don't
forget about them
um
[Music]
so where does this happen on scene play
right so on scene play
we'll do on-run time
there you go man there you go visual
studio okay
uh what is it it's active scene look at
that
active scene on my computer just i think
my computer's more tired than i am from
all the programming today to be
completely honest on runtime stop
uh it doesn't really matter like what
order you do it in i did it in
i did it in the opposite order of this
in the dev branch i'll do it in this
order here why not um but basically
these two functions right which we will
implement um these two functions are
going to create and destroy our box 2d
world so uh we'll include box2d here so
include um what is it uh
box2d slash b2 underscore world from
memory
not sure why that's not helping me until
a sense intelligence has been kind of
broken all day anyway but um uh what is
the box 2d world equals new
b2 world there you go intellisense is
back catching up with me so gravity
right it's a v two it's a b b two vec b
two b b two vector box to a vector two
so no horizontal and then we'll use
minus nine point eight that's the kind
of nine point eight what is it meters
per second the normal gravity we have i
think on this planet i'm not a not a
not a physics person so i don't know
sure checks out um
might want to look might want to look
that up uh i'll do i'll call it this
physics world right
come on
i'm using like one of my old keyboards
it's a dust keyboard i think three but
it's the ultimate version which has no
like
no um
the the keys are blank basically it
doesn't have any actual
letters text glyphs whatever on the keys
so
if i miss a key if i'm just typing it's
fine but then if i have to press a key
and especially a symbol don't ask me to
because i'll be like oh no i'll start
doubting myself it's a disaster anyway
probably not great for recording videos
but whatever um so yeah so we created
this box 2d world and this happens of
course inside our uh kind of
on runtime start function and then what
we want to do now is actually go through
okay well actually since we have since
we've created we might as well destroy
it so we basically do delete and then
we'll uh
also set this to null pointer because of
course the scene isn't dying um so we
want to make sure that if in case we're
debugging or whatever that it is in fact
null points and not whatever memory
address was left over that we deleted
deleted the data from
um
yeah so what do we do next well now that
we have the world we want to start
adding bodies to it how do we do that we
call the create body function but we
need to know what entities are actual
physics entities that need to be created
so we need to create some kind of
physics component so if we hop on over
into our components file go to the very
bottom i'm going to make a area here
called
just physics i guess struct
um let me pop on over into the right
file over here as well so that i can see
uh like what i actually did but we'll
call this
rigidbody2d component so everything in
hazel i'm pretty sure potentially apart
from no okay sprite render has that as
well um they all end in component just
so that it's completely clear
um but we don't have too many things
here um i mean enum class body type
right so we have a type for the body so
static which is zero again i like to
explicitly write it just to
be on the same page just in case but
it's not really necessary it should be
zero anyway static dynamic kinematic um
kinematic i don't think we're gonna deal
with that today but um
it's not so in other words we're not um
and then we can actually set it to be i
guess body type static by default like
that
right um now the other parameter that we
might want is basically whether or not
rotation is fixed so you might want it
to not be able to rotate right that's
useful to have um and that's kind of it
now other things we're going to include
here though are a little void pointer
this could be a forward declared b2 body
pointer but basically this is going to
be the actual runtime body so we're
gonna inside the component itself we're
actually gonna store
the runtime body now i don't know why
necessarily i decided on this
architecture i did this like over a year
ago for for big hazel um you could
easily have like a map of
entity id we don't have uuids yet
parentheses but you could easily have a
map of that to
these void pointers or to b2 body
pointers if you wanted to in the scene
so scene could own that i don't know if
shoving it into into a component's a
great idea but then again i don't think
it matters too much unless you believe
in the whole they should be immutable i
don't really know um i think it's fine
this is eight bytes of memory it's just
going to be a pointer to a runtime body
so that we can keep track of it through
box 2d that's all it is um
that's it right so after that we create
a default constructor
and again i just like to be explicit
about this and then we create a
copy constructor as well i guess we can
just do that if we wanted to but
um
yeah i guess what's the point of running
other
um okay there you go so that's the rigid
body 2d component now i want to do the
same thing
now but we'll do it for the box collider
2d component right so this is going to
actually represent the box um that we
are going to
that is our collision box right so it
does not have to match the sprite
obviously it can be whatever you want it
to be
um so let's get rid of this stuff with
the exception of we'll keep this we'll
call this runtime fixture because we'll
have to we will we will want to be able
to kind of um reference that so we will
create an offset which we're not
actually going to use today
but this will just be for future
reference this is if you want your
collider to be offset from the middle of
your entity right
um from the mid from the basically from
the transform position um size as well
by default we'll set it up to be 0.5
um so this will line up well with a one
by one meter sprite which again if you
create like a sprite renderer component
it's gonna be a one by one meter
um like according to its transform a one
a one by one scale i guess one by one by
one scale
means that you have a one by one meter
object so this is going to basically
follow that convention because these are
half extents so you will still end up
with a one by one meter thing
now um the rest of the stuff is
basically like physics materials stuff
so we have a density which i just said
to one by default i don't know if these
are good default values this just is
what it is friction i think i said to
you at 0.5 and then we basically have
two things so we have restitution which
is the bounciness kind of it's like
something to do with energy and how much
is lost and then also a restitution
threshold so this is important because i
think i've set it to 0.5 and then by
default it's not bouncy right yeah so
this is just a threshold at which
velocity again the docs explain this
greatly um
the
what this is the velocity at which it
stops
like
calculating the bounciness because as
you can imagine if you drop something on
a table it could keep bouncing in like
forever right infinitely because it's
just going to keep like bouncing um and
we don't want the physics engine to have
to keep calculating that and we'll get
weird jitters like so you usually just
say this to like something decent was
like okay well if the speed has fallen
below this amount i don't know if 0.5 is
a decent value whatever seemed to
visually look fine
and you can obviously tweak this that's
the point of exposing this value but
this basically just means that it's not
going to it's going to just quit after a
while and be like okay no more balancing
which is i think important um all right
that's it so this stuff i'll add the
same to do i did in the dev branch which
was
um basically move into physics
material in the future maybe
um so that we move this uh basically
into an actual physics material because
that's kind of what it is so now we have
those two components right we can
basically do the rest of the code here
now we still need to set up the ui and
the serialization for those components
right so remind me um this is not a live
stream but remind me
um from the past so back into scene
right how do we set the stuff up well
basically once we have our physics world
we we really just need to go through
somehow so we'll use a view to go
through our entity component system
through our registry um and basically
look at all of the rigid body
yeah definitely that rigid body 2d
components that we have right so for
auto
uh we'll do e
in view and then we'll immediately just
create like a hazel entity out of it so
e and then i think this right um so that
we can like use our own api i guess
which is like a wrapper over
ent over entity
so once we have that um we need to
basically pull some data so what are we
trying to do we're trying to create
bodies into the physics world we're
trying to create some bodies at
particular locations with particular
sizes set up their colliders do all that
stuff so we obviously need to pull the
transform out so we'll do transform
equals e get component do we actually
have
no
uh
why is this so difficult
um do we have
no okay so and i think in hazel in um
proper hazel we have a dot transform
function that we can just use and it's
shorthand for pulling out the transform
components because it's such a common
thing to do but we'll basically and this
is obviously with entity so entity get
component transform uh rb2d rigidbody2d
so this is our rigidbody2d component
which we just made
um what else do we need that's probably
it so now we can actually start creating
a body so in order to be able to
actually do create body you can see we
need a body def that's like a body
definition right so um
basically b2 body def right this is our
body definition and then we can start
filling it out now i think we'll
probably have to like include body and
while we're here we might as well
include fixture probably it do we need
like shape we're going to use a box
collider so is there like a
shape
polygon shape i think we'll use
yeah
include everything this is all the box
2d stuff
um so we to we'll pass that in so it
just takes it in as a constant pointer
like that it's going to copy all the
stuff internally i'm pretty sure well it
definitely does because this will go out
of scope obviously um and then we
basically set up all the stuff we need
to for our bodies the main things in the
body again are things that we have here
the type and the rotation and that's
that's it from the rigidbody component
but then from the transform component we
need to set the position of it and stuff
like that but the first thing we
probably care about is the type right so
to set this type um i think it's good to
like create a little conversion function
so that we don't have to have if
statements or a switch case in here
because we need to now convert from our
kind of hazel type static dynamic
kinematic to box 2ds type i don't know
if the enum will line up because you
could just like type on it or copy the
value or whatever interpret it whatever
you want
yeah you you could static kinematic
dynamic
um
we defined it in a different order as
will be different i don't like you could
so i'll show you how to do that i'm not
going to do that just because i like to
be a bit more explicit with my
conversions but basically what you could
do is basically take
our rigid body 2d because they're just
integers obviously and just be like no
no it's this done right i don't think
it'll let you apply this just because
they will show up at different types but
if you cast it it will be fine
you could do that again in this case we
we would have to switch dynamic and
kinematic but i'm not going to do that
i'm going to write a conversion function
so to do that we'll just do static
what's the actual type b2 body type
um we'll do hazel uh
what did i call the function hazel rigid
body
2d
type 2 box 2d
to box 2d type basically so um
so this will be a
rigid rigidbody 2d component
body type so this is the body type
we're taking that in and we're
converting it here so you can just do a
switch statement for this of course body
type
and then what do we do case
body type static will return
static
so yeah this is just a bit nicer in
general just because you don't have to
worry about
um
[Music]
you know this is kind of since we've
defined our own types for it it's nice
to be a little bit more in control with
conversions just in case they change
stuff around because obviously they
assume if you use an enum it doesn't
really matter what the value is unless
you serialize it and then again i like
serializing enum values as strings
rather than as
numbers unless you are doing a binary
format for runtime that's fine but in
terms of like for an editor definitely
serialize it as a string because that
way it doesn't really matter
um you know what's up uh
so
will chorus at false because
that's an unknown type
unknown body
type
i don't know do we need a dot a full
stop no um and we'll just return a thing
just so it's happy but yeah so now that
we've got this we can convert from um
i guess i won't call this hazel because
we are hazel right rigid body 2d type
that's hazel's one obviously to box to
the
type
to box city body
um so now that we've got that we can of
course do this instead it's a little bit
more robust than just assuming that the
you know why not
um
and also in case you're wondering why we
don't use
why we don't just use box 2ds types here
i just don't like to just because i
don't i don't like to be dependent on
that right like if we decide that we
want to change
um over to use like not box 2d for
whatever reason you know there's a lot
of box studio references all around the
code i like to be a little bit more kind
of abstract i guess a bit further away
from implementation details so we just
roll our own stuff and then you know we
can add translation where necessary
obviously this stuff is it's not like
gonna affect performance or anything
we're in runtime start and we're doing a
little little light light little
conversion so everything's fine
there's gonna be another monster episode
well it was a four-hour live stream what
do you expect um but at least we're
getting we're getting stuff done you
know for hazel 2d which which i think is
important because i'm getting a bit fed
up with how long it's taking us to
get to anything uh at least capable of
making a small game so um the position
now so the position obviously coming
from the transform it's great that we
store stuff like not as matrices because
it's just so easy to grab these values
we don't need to decompose anything i
mean translation is a bad example
because that's easy to get from a matrix
regardless but stuff like scale and
rotation especially um it's so nice when
it's just stored like this
speaking of rotation we'll also set the
angle notice that's just a float of
course because we're in 2d physics land
so this will simply be um
what
transform.rotation.z basically
transform.rotation.z
all right
so that's our body def
pretty much done
i think now we can actually create the
body by passing in that body depth and
we have our body ready to go we need to
pull that out though so b2 body pointer
um we'll just call this body i guess uh
so this this is going to be our actual
body that we want to store back in the
component when we wrote it right so we
have a runtime body so this just keeps
track of it during runtime otherwise
it's null pointer right
so
uh oh and finally we need to actually
set fixed rotation this happens
in the um
like in the body not the body depth so
what is it going to be
rb2d dot fixed rotation there's a lot of
other stuff by the way i'm arbitrarily
picking stuff i don't know even how i
came up okay came up with what gets
included what doesn't but like if you
look at set fixed rotation like there's
um you know we can have enabled disabled
there's obviously fixed lists there's
joints there's a lot of stuff to do
right um and obviously even like stuff
in hazel that already does exist in
in the in the in big hazel is like stuff
like contact listeners so being able to
get callbacks into your scripts when
collisions occur triggers stuff like
that that's all ahead of us we will get
there probably one day but for now
obviously starting with the first pass
um
yeah and now that we've got this we can
go back into that thing and set that
runtime body to just be the body right
it's a void pointer because we don't
want to include box2d there again
nothing wrong with just making a forward
declaration like we did here um
that's okay i think but i just kept it
as a void pointer whatever it doesn't
really matter we know what it is um it's
not a big deal
now
we could go through this again
except this time checking for box
collider 2d stuff um but instead of that
i'm just going to do if and again
from an empty component system i don't
know if this is
what this is might be worse than just
iterating through all of them in a row
but this is on runtime start not a big
deal i think could change it later if we
need to but it's just
code wise is a lot it's a lot better to
just have it here so we'll just do um if
entity has component box glider 2d
component we can add an actual box kind
of
collider to it basically so we'll get
that box collider 2d component from it
which will be entity get component
this right
and then we can start creating an actual
shape out of it so b2 polygon shape
that's what i included earlier
so we'll make the actual uh
i guess polygon shape could have called
it shape i guess
uh shape dot set as box and then we set
the half extents and you can see it says
half width half height they're even
labeled hx hy
so
we could obviously just set this to be
the uh x and the y right and oh there is
a center so we can actually pass the
offset into here that's cool i didn't
realize that during the live stream but
basically um there's even an overload
what's the other one all right with
center and angle
oh but that's an oriented box this is an
access align box
um we won't play with this just just yet
um so we'll basically we we could just
set this to be the uh size dot x and
then the size dot y
um which is fine but what i want to do
is i want to make this not just like an
absolute size that we set because you
know i mean intuitively you want to be
able to just resize your box your
renderable box in the actual engine by
just dragging like on the scale and
making the scale larger and you're
making it a non-uniform scale or
whatever i want to you know build some
walls and stuff like that and then i
don't want to manually go into the box
collider 2d component and then
i don't know be like oh okay now it's 20
meters tall so i guess i'll manually set
the y to be 10. like that's just silly
right so instead of doing that
um we
what we do since we are already kind of
living in a situation where
like we have scale and we're in a one by
one like you know one a scale of one
means one meter so clearly half of this
means half of that and the half extents
work and stuff like that so because of
that i i'm like i think it's a great
idea to basically just be like you know
what transform.scale.x
i'll multiply this with this size x and
stuff like that right so
i might do it the other way around um
just so that's a bit more clear in the
code but uh you know if we multiply with
scale it means that we automatically get
that scale value in here we'll change it
to y and everything's fine now if you
want to modify that so you want it to be
like a
you know maybe different like twice a
scale or whatever you can do that and i
think if if people really have an issue
with this
you can easily add a little checkbox to
be like don't use scale or use scale
and then have a check by default or
whatever and then that way you cannot do
this here um
but otherwise you know if you wanna if
you just wanna custom hard-coded value
of course it can be a little bit
difficult to do but again if you have a
scale of one you can have whatever value
you want because you'll multiply with
one so i don't know i think it's good to
do this
uh it just makes a lot more sense when
you're actually
you know using the engine
unity does this i'm fairly sure
um okay so now we set up the fixture so
the fixture is going to contain this
shape that we just made a little polygon
shape
right um i guess we should call this a
box shape actually because that makes
more sense
um and then
all the kind of material stuff that i
just talked about right so stuff like
the density the friction you know all
that stuff so where do we get it from we
get it from that box collider again
that's why i put it there it might have
made more sense to put it onto the
actual rigid body but you can see that
box 2d stores it in the fixture which
the fixture needs the shape right so
it's all kind of you know connected i
guess so we'll get the density from
there then we'll get the friction
uh then what else is there the
restitution and the restitution
threshold
right so once we've got all of this
stuff restitution
um restitution threshold
and friction right we just create the
fixture so we go body which we still
have because we're up here that's
another good example of like why i kind
of did it all in one for loop not in
several kind of iterations going through
different components just because we
already have everything here it makes
sense
create fixture and then we'll pass in
that fixture def
all right fantastic so that is pretty
much it
for runtime start i don't think that's
anything else that we need to do so
that's fantastic we've created all of
the entities within box 2d itself we've
got those um you know beautiful orange
lines that i drew earlier so now what do
we have to do every frame
well
usually you would want to do this after
you update the script i think at least
in hazel we like to do physics
after we do the script so like with
physx and for 3d physics we do it after
the reason being the way that i kind of
justify this in my head is just that
the script can control the physics the
script might be like i want to add an
impulse i want to add a force and
obviously that will not get picked up
until the next frame
unless you actually
um do the calculation after you do that
right so in other words what you're kind
of the thing you're kind of playing with
here is the the render order right
versus like the you know the script s
and then the physics so if you do
script physics render then the script
affects the physics and you can already
see that in the render otherwise if you
do
physics script render right then
obviously the physics will happen you'll
add your impulse but you'll render
obviously from the physics
so you won't get that impulse until the
next frame so that's kind of how i
that's why i did it that way um
again i don't know what arguments people
have i didn't think about it for too
long to be honest but whatever so
you know
physics
so um we'll probably start using stop
using like 2d all the time because this
is a 2d engine but like for this i want
to make it clear that this is a box
collider 2d and that's 2d just because
just because i want to
um so how do we do this so i i kind of
arbitrarily i think this comes from the
either the documentation from box 2d or
possibly it's from the uh one of their
examples but basically we have velocity
and position iterations this is
basically
controlling the granularity of the
physics simulation so how much is it
stepping how how often is it doing
calculations between moving and stuff
like that if you increase this
performance is going to go down but the
precision will go up so i don't know
what good values are this is definitely
open for
debate and i think that you should
definitely probably expose this to the
editor in some kind of physics settings
because it will definitely depend on
what kind of game you're making and you
know what app you're making what
simulate what scene you have and stuff
like that so we pass in the time step
which is just ts and then obviously what
we just created velocity iterations
position iterations
all right so next step is to
basically retrieve those rigid bodies
from the world so that we can actually
uh
you know
update them so what do we have to update
well we've just stepped the physics
world which means we've simulated the
physics so now obviously the positions
of things have moved around right the
positions of these orange things have
moved around so now we have to grab
those transforms so that the white
squares that we actually render
all of our entities in the right place
so to do that um you know we'll go
through uh auto um e in view just like
we did before
um
uh so yeah i'll i guess i'll make that
clear so retrieve uh
transform
from box 2d
right
so
uh we'll make that entity like we did
before and e this
and then we'll just we'll basically
scroll up here and get the transform and
the rigid body 2d components because we
need those and then that's kind of like
it like it's really quite simple all we
have to do is grab that physics body
which remember we are now nicely storing
inside here so we can just do
run time body that's a void pointer i'm
going to cast it back to
one of these you guys can use static
cast or interpret cast if you want we
had a discussion during the live stream
and i kind of agreed that you know i
just like see so i just like see
stylecast i think it's fine and i think
it's necessary um to write static cast
or or interpret cast here um this is
avoid pointer and we're just cursing
back to here um
now
if you didn't store it on the component
this is where you'd probably want to
also retrieve maybe the entity uuid or
whatever and then be like hey scene you
know
give me my entity box 2d
body map and then i want to
um you know i want to get my entity
id and then that way you could kind of
get your body that's the only other way
i can really think of doing it um
sure right but the data's already here
it's already hot in the cache i guess
because we're
going through this anyway and which we
need to get the values out anyway from
the component i guess
so
i don't know
i think it's fine um i guess we don't
really like we do need to go through the
rigidbody2d component to know what even
to set what entities to set but
um
i don't know i think it's fine doing it
this way
all right
and it's not that i sound like you know
insecure or defensive of my strategy i'm
just literally thinking out loud that's
all um i don't really care like i'm
happy for people to correct me obviously
so now we get the position from the body
so get position i'm purely using this
constant reference as an alias if you
look at get position it returns a const
reference of this i just don't want to
write get position twice that's all
um
this will probably all be inlined anyway
obviously so uh transform.translation.x
right so we can set that x translation
to be position.x right that's from box
2d and then we do the same for y so
we're just copying the
x and y position from box 2d
into our transform component thus
changing our transform component
pretty wild stuff i know um and then
we'll do the same thing for the rotation
so the z rotation will now be position
not position obviously will now be body
i think it's get angle right because
that's what we called it and that's it
and this angle i think is a float right
so there we go there's our angle we've
got the rotation z everything looks
brilliant and believe it or not guys
that's actually it
um
that's actually it we need to program
all the ui but fundamentally
functionally that is actually it so
let's try and build this i know it's
going to fail because of a few annoying
things but we'll still build it um see
how far we get i guess
um
[Music]
okay that succeeded i'm surprised
because i thought we were missing some
like of these annoying things
but whatever i don't think we're
actually calling out a component yeah
that's why um so how do we add can add
this stuff right we'll do this
utilization last we'll start with the um
with the scene hierarchy right so we
obviously need to be able to
um add these actual entities how do we
add like a camera sorry not entities
components so we have ad component this
is one thing that annoyed me during the
live stream why on earth would we um
have this set up
i don't know if i wrote this or not i
don't remember i don't care but
you know in this case it's like if you
don't have the component at it otherwise
just
write something don't add the component
obviously and just write a little log
message that's weird what we should do
is not even present that as an option
if the component already exists right
and by the way if we want to have
multiple box collider components that
needs to be a completely different
system so we'll talk about that later
when we get there but um that's
definitely like i guess there are use
cases for that and it's probably best to
have like a box 2d collider or like a
a box collider collection component or
something that contains many
you know shapes and and box colliders
within it that's probably how i would do
it
but yeah if we don't have that then
we'll add that and also cleans up the
code which is nice doing it this way
um so let's do that
right all good now we'll copy this and
we'll give ourselves a way to add both a
rigid body component
right
so rigid
body
rigid body 2d
as well as
a
box
collider 2d component
i should um
just locate check my disk space and
stuff because i always get annoyed like
i always get worried and stressed about
these long videos just
failing to record or whatever
hate that
box collider 2d and uh rigidbody2d right
box collateral okay that looks good um
so now we have the ability to add it but
we want to obviously tweak the ui and
stuff so let's go ahead and the hardest
one is probably going to be
let's copy the camera one
the reason being that well actually
we'll copy the sprite renderer but then
we'll grab some stuff from camera
because we have a drop down box right
and they're always fun to do because we
have this like checkbox it's not
checkbox but we have to be able to to
actually um
select what body type we use so we have
static we have dynamic
uh and we have what is i'm doing from
memory by the way just because um well
this is ui stuff it's easy but
i just did this a few hours ago i'm
gonna be have dreams about box 2d and
stuff yeah
um so body type body type strings
current body type string body type
strings
um and then component so this is uh
coming from
component dot
um i'm still doing sprite render
component so this is oh i better not be
modifying the actual sprite running
component good i'm not so this is the
rigid body 2d component
component.type
i think
this is useless
yep type
cast to it ins
um getting that stuff out current body
type so this is our body type
we'll put in our current body type
so basically current progression string
gets replaced with that and projection
type strings gets replaced with body
type strings
and everything else should work apart
from setting it so to set it we just do
component
dot
body dot type
equals um
this is slightly annoying but rigid
body
intellisense being useless as usual
although i did misspell that i guess
body type uh
i right
um that's it i think i don't think i did
anything with cameras or projections i
don't think i left anything there
whatever we'll debug it if anything so
that looks good that's our body type um
what else do we have inside that rigid
body component so just just fixed
rotation is the only other thing which
is kind of nice so
i think this is just a checkbox
we really need to redo this ui as well
because we've still got labels on the
right side and you need to integrate
some new ui if you guys haven't seen the
new ui by the way i'll have it linked up
there um if i remember but it's the
latest kind of hazel devlog check that
out it looks so good and we're going to
start probably bringing some of that
back into here as well so
what is this fixed rotation
um
so
let's see
thanks for the help
oh no
oh no
my whole computer is frozen
okay so i almost just had a heart attack
because my computer froze this mouse
would not move for like
a few minutes
but the rook i stopped the recording and
the recording
after it unfroze and the recording is
safe
i was almost about i was an hour and
eight minutes into that recording man if
that
no
it's not good for my heart
anyway let's get back to it so
at least i have the first part saved i
wouldn't mind resuming from here if i
anyway so component fixed rotation um
that's easy enough
so
so we've got that going um now we just
need to do the same kind of thing but
for the uh box collider
stuff
so box platter 2d component
box collider 2d
don't need any of this stuff obviously
uh it's actually pretty simple we just
need to basically have um an im gui like
drag float two i guess
for the
so yeah all this stuff from here
basically so let's maybe just kind of
display that side by side or something
um so that we can quickly see it nothing
really to do here so we'll have our
offset
which will be glm value pointer
component
dot offset
[Music]
and then we'll have
size
density
friction
and these are just track floats
density friction residue restitution and
residual threshold
that's it right okay
so these are all just component dot
uh now because restitution so if you
read the docs right
um restitution
hard word um if you read the docs then
you'll see that
um
these values like threshold not but like
these values are mostly between like
zero and one right actually i think it's
not even the docs i think it's just like
the code that says that so if you look
at like density or whatever that's our
density
um
it says that like yeah usually in the
range zero one so friction restitution
so you don't have to lock it to zero one
because again
usually in the range means that like
not necessarily
you know
like it could for whatever special
effects you might want to exceed that
range
but again like i don't know if it's
worth locking and having a button that's
like unlocked because again for most
purposes you might want to lock it
um but yeah i think what we'll do is we
will lock it for now so 0.01 will be the
speed and then 0 1 will do
all right same friction same for
restitution but for the threshold
we'll have 0 as the minimum um so this
speed so if you're up on one speed zero
minimum and we won't have a maximum
um because yeah
okay that's it i think i know weird
checkbox here but that's basically it oh
like offset offset everywhere yeah
basically yeah well done cherno um so
component dot density
this all needs to be removed
uh density we've got restitution and we
just need friction
okay so that's basically it i think um
have we just done like everything that
we needed to do
i feel like we might we may have so
let's go ahead and hit f5 and see what
happens um again serialization is the
big thing we haven't done yet we want to
be able to save our components okay this
is what i was talking about so we need
to have
um
i don't know why i did this man i was a
bit i was kind of upset upset of myself
on stream for doing this at some point i
guess but like why do we even have these
i guess if we want to trigger these
events when
they get when certain components get
added like this but
i don't know they're kind of enforced
everywhere which is weird maybe we
should make them optional somehow i
don't know it's just going to try and
call it if it can't find the
if you can't find the function it's
linking error so it's not the best thing
um but anyway uh we'll just we'll just
shut up and add them here in this case
copy that across
um and yeah now we should be able to i
don't know if we've done everything
correctly i haven't really referred to
my notes much
i've just had the screen recorder here
so i can make sure everything's
recording um but uh if we go to scenes
physics 2d
if we hit play
will we
will we see it fall that's the moment of
truth guys are you ready
play
i failed
i failed you all oh no no i haven't
failed anyone i haven't added the
components yet
so add component rigidbody2d add
component box collativity so rigidbody2d
over here we'll set it to be a dynamic
um body of course we'll leave everything
else as default now let's hit play
i didn't fail anyone okay cool now
notice how when i hit stop it's gone
it's not actually gone it's just down
here because obviously
um at the moment when we hit play it
plays the existing scene there's no
resetting scenes usually what you do
what what you would want to do and what
we do in hazel and big hazel is we copy
the entire scene when we hit play so
it's like a new scene it's like a
runtime scene that you're playing and
then that way you delete that scene when
you hit stop and you fall back to the
editor scene
so that's how we do it and that's
probably what we'll do here maybe next
episode because that is definitely
important but yeah let's add another
entity we can't save any of this which
is annoying we should probably add
serialization first but it but just just
to kind of test it we'll add another
entity
um we'll uh let's just uh
move this down a little bit i'll
actually add like a non-uniform kind of
scale so we'll test that out if that
works maybe let's back the camera
back a little bit more
and then i'll add a
box collider to it and i will add
a rigid body 2d to it we'll make it
static this time let's hit play
there you go right it sits on the box
amazing and of course we could rotate
this
and it will kind of roll that's great um
and then also let's do one more thing
might back that camera up even more it'd
be nice to have like a picture and
picture for the camera so we can see
what it says but
the other thing we'll do is uh maybe um
well
let's set the restitution of this a bit
higher
right it's like 0.5 so now it should
bounce
hey it's a bit bouncy now right
so that's it basically you can see it
all working um did not take that much
time did it
um yeah pretty easy to do
the gizmos are using the wrong camera
but yeah that's a little bouncy world
now we can't duplicate entities either
right which would be great because we'll
probably add that next episode when we
actually add the
um scene copying and stuff because a lot
of the same code can be used to
duplicate entities but uh
yeah that's basically it so we can't
save that's our last thing so how do we
save well saving very easy right um we
just need to manually add the stuff into
c serializer now again if we had some
kind of automatic reflection system
probably wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world because it would save us a lot
of manual code
but on the other hand i kind of like the
simplicity of this stuff um
you know we don't have to have anything
crazy people understand how this system
works
um and obviously once you kind of have
your components in place like it's just
something you do for components so i
don't know i'm a bit torn
um i kind of like it to be honest
um so uh rb2d component
so we'll retrieve this component if it
has it of course um and then we just
need to serialize all the values which
again we just have static dynamic
kinematic um and then fixed rotation
right but the thing is with the body
type i want to serialize it as a string
not an integer i mentioned this before
just in case we rearrange stuff or we
like i mean it's not that bad here these
are kind of fixed right but in general
it's it also makes it easier to read the
actual yaml file if it's text and of
course it's yaml so we're we're trying
to make it easy to read easy to merge
you know human readable and writable
even so it's nice to kind of do that so
let's add a little function probably up
here
and we'll call this so scd string um
this will be a rigid
body 2d
uh
body type i guess really body 2d body
type 2 string
body type
body
type
and then i'll kind of do the same thing
but this will be a from string because
we'll obviously need that as well
this will kind of just be
rearranged
body type string
okay so how's this going to work well uh
we'll just do a switch for this case so
body type
case
static
will return
static
dynamic
kinematic
uh we'll return an empty string in a set
i don't know why this would happen
um anyway
memory corruption maybe
catch some like memory corruption bugs
all right
so there you go static dynamic kinematic
um and then
uh for this though because they're
strings and string comparisons and stuff
we can't use switch statements so we'll
just do
uh if the body type string is static
return
this
static dynamic kinematic
return
just static i guess and assert
if it's for some reason neither of these
okay
easy so now
uh we do two string for the
serialization so it's going to be
this
body type or just type
and then finally for the fixed rotation
we'll just do
the fixed rotation
um that's good uh now we'll do the same
thing for the
box collide but again we can't save it's
the stupidest thing i don't know how we
didn't end up having a save button
whatever this episode's already long
anyway might as well just you know
hope you guys are appreciating this
series series
um
yeah lots of time it's okay i'm enjoying
myself i guess
uh box collider 2d
box collider 2d component and then we
have uh what do we even have in that
we've got quite a lot of stuff so offset
size so i don't think we have any um
and again i've been through this in the
live stream so when i say i don't think
i'm i'm sure i'm just
pretending that i don't know what i'm
talking about i don't know why but uh we
don't have any vector two kind of
functions so if you look up we have
vector three vector four we don't
support kind of serializing vector twos
so we'll add that in uh it's pretty
simple we'll just get rid of z and we're
done
and then finally we'll do the same thing
for like decoding them basically so
you can just kind of convert note as
well so two two get rid of this
two
get rid of this two
right and that's it pretty simple
so now we can serialize and deserialize
vectors pretty easily
um
where was all this stuff uh offset size
uh what else do we have so yeah density
friction
density
friction
restitution
restitution threshold and i'll just copy
that
and that looks good
okay that's it that's our box collider
component done
uh now obviously the deserializing stage
so
rigid body
2d component
uh
so rigid body 2d
what do we have runtime body
runtime body the the perfect thing to
serialize so rigid body to the
uh
from string right so we're reading the
string
um
um body type right dot
as a city string
then we convert it
fixed rotation
as bull
that's it and then for the
box collider
2d component
box collider 2d
so
what do we have in there
um
make sure we do that
so
[Music]
uh i guess offset is the first thing
right
glm vector
have another vector which is the size
and then the rest of floats
starting with density
friction
restitution
sure
restitution
threshold and restitution okay so
in there we go looks like i'm falling
asleep
doing this card i don't know if you guys
are like you know watching this on two
times speed or just skipping it entirely
i'll try and put chapters if i don't
forget in the uh
description so that
they show up and then you can navigate
this easier and skip this boring part
but
i think that's it so now we can save it
kind of we just don't have a control s
button but whatever we'll add we'll add
that stuff next time because i think
that it's going to be um
it's going to be like you know we'll add
all the scene functionality we'll add um
being able to duplicate entities we'll
have to save scene stuff so it'll make
sense to kind of just do that all in one
episode i think
um okay uh what's going on with our
editor
oh
i have this window on top for some
reason so um physics 2d we're back to
having nothing that's great let's try
and build out our scene again so add
rigid body add box collider
we'll set this to be dynamic
and then let's create our floor so i'll
call this floor
i'll add a sprite renderer a rigid body
basically all the components have a
camera um we'll make this static um i'll
probably change the color to like orange
because i like orange that's all we had
in the other demo i'm fairly sure
um
make this like this
um
make this maybe a bit smaller
um and then obviously make this yeah
static and all that stuff now let's save
this so save as and then we'll just
overwrite physics 2d
yes
play there you go right so we have our
kind of scene
um we'll move this away obviously we can
play with this we can also try and make
it like longer you know it should work i
guess because we obviously played with
that
um also i guess we'll check out the
friction so if we make this
rotated how how does it slide so it
doesn't slide at the moment but if we
lower the friction so 0.5 um let's make
it like point one maybe
then you can see it slides now right
so the sliding's there let's rescue it
uh and yeah i think that's pretty much
it you guys probably get it don't need
to sit here playing with it um i'll push
this what's already on the dev branch
but it'll also be in the main branch now
so i will push this you guys can play
with it at home if you like
um
but yeah uh bounciness is probably the
last thing we didn't really
touch since we did the changes but
let's go to yeah let's just make it kind
of bouncy
i'll make it a bit bigger maybe
no that's that's too big
um density is probably also useful
to play with
makes a bit more crazy anyway um that's
basically it right so
uh i hope you enjoyed the episode
you got to have it on a bit of an angle
otherwise
lol
there you go fun times so that's how it
works um again if we add duplicating
functionality we'll play with this more
next time we can set up entire maze um
otherwise making these entities from
scratch is really annoying um but yeah
that's it so again i'll i'll save this
physics 2d
and then i'm going to load like pink
cube right
and then i'll go back to physics 2d and
we have all of our stuff and it works
right so that is it i hope you guys
enjoyed this video this very long video
of us doing 2d physics
box 2d uh again not that difficult to
implement i think
um you know we went from scratch to
having it in you know if you don't if
you know what you what what you're doing
it's quite quick but obviously if you're
doing it for the first time it will take
longer it took me longer the first time
i did it obviously
which was years ago but uh hopefully
this was kind of beneficial to you guys
not just if you're following along with
hazel and you want to learn but also
maybe for your own engines like that um
again nothing really to it just need to
know kind of what you're doing which the
documentation is a perfect place for so
don't skip the docs read the docs at
least a little bit learn to read not
just copy code um it's very it'll help
you out in the long run i promise you
but anyway i hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button patreon.com the
channel best way to help support this
series get access to hazel uh 3d to the
full version kind of hazel to the to to
not just hazel 2d but you know all of
the massive work that's gone into that
um and obviously help support this
series as well if there were no patreon
supporting hazel the big version there
would be no hazel little version or
hazel 2d right or at least it wouldn't
be at this stage um at all so thank you
huge thank you to everyone for
supporting this of course i'll be back
with a live stream next thursday
australian time as usual
but until then have a great recipe day
and i'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you